you know what the average police
response time in is in i would love to
know 20 minutes
20 minutes is the average response time
reported in 2021 new york is
uh new york city is 7.7 minutes oh and
now forget it yeah right forget it now
right
right so
what think about what can happen in
seven minutes think about what can
happen in seven seconds
think about what can happen in 20
minutes
think about someone who when i when i
like have these discussions i come from
cities and people who come from cities
you know you're used to like oh the
police station's right there and you
hear sirens all the time and think about
someone who lives in a rural area
you could be waiting what would you sit
around oh criminals at the door let me
just call
i got 20 minutes to spare up let me cook
up and fry an egg or some sausage on no
this is these are moments of terror and
these are moments where every second
counts forget about every minute so
understand what just stretch your mind
for a second even if you are inclined to
disagree and just see where people are
coming from who have a little baby at
home what about a single mom
i'm a little person
i can kick some ass in the gym and i can
box and i can do all of that
and i know how to duck a shot and i have
great balance and i have all that great
pat myself in the back there you go judd
but bottom line is
i'm a little person somebody comes to
the door and they're armed i'm
i'm probably going to be in trouble so
it's an equalizer for women in many ways
think about it just think about a single
mom sitting at home like get into the
heads of those people when you have
these discussions it's so important to
just step out of whatever your situation
is
just step into someone else's situation
for a second just for a second
if you like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode right here
[Music]